hi this is Alexander Bernal again with
another snow update today I'm going to
show you the changes we've made in our
m3 build first off we've upgraded the
CryEngine 3.6 what this means for the
user is that we now use physically based
rendering you will immediately notice
that the game world looks more vibrant
as materials and textures are now more
physically correct and consistent with
realistic lighting we've also begun work
on a new time of day with this upgrade
we've also fixed a lot of bugs that have
been plaguing users and made further
optimization improvements for low-end
computers the sense of speed has been
greatly improved thanks to motion blur
and improvements to physics you should
now gain speed properly and feel like
you're really going fast in m3 we have
completely new animations these
animations and a few animation systems
will greatly improve the look and feel
of the game making riding more fluid and
graceful for example we now have a
switch tucked animation for when you're
riding switch and want to gain speed we
have a whole bunch of variations for
riding forward when stopped and for
different types of landings after being
in the air finally at the request of the
community we've also added a new grab
scream and Seamon pushing has been
reworked to function as intended you no
longer need to span the push key to
start moving you can either hold down
push to push normally repeatedly press
the key to push fail faster finally we
have added the long-awaited founders
sets to the game this set of items will
only be available to users who purchase
the game through early access we'll also
be adding upgrade paths for those of you
who want to buy a higher tier to get the
full set more news on that soon
and as usual thank you for watching and
thank you for all the feedback